all right welcome in it is galentine's
day The Unofficial day to celebrate with
your gal Pals and Tony too interesting
fact you know galentine's day actually
all started on the sitcom Parks and
Recreation oh I didn't realize that all
right so it's a day to celebrate female
friendships and you got to have a
bartender right that's why Heather and I
are here celebrating with a special
punch from libertine social Tony
abiganum is here joins us now to show us
how to make it welcome hey Sherry nice
to see you happy Valentine's Day great
spread uh we're excited well punch is
such a fun thing to do and you can just
Riff on different recipes as long as you
have a base Spirit some fruitiness and
and some champagne yes bubbles so that's
the key why don't we get mixing okay
let's do it I'm gonna have you make one
Alma nude okay so I want you to add uh
one and a half ounces of each of these
juices one and a half ounces lemon sour
you have Palm wonderful pomegranate and
here you have white grape juice and what
is one and a half ounces all the way to
the top and right into the mixer got it
now Sherry the thing about punch make it
in advance okay um ice will keep a cold
drink cold so you make it in advance you
pour it over ice and it's beautiful yeah
just pour that weight in there and show
them the ice cubes Tony because they're
frozen
thank you and that is absolutely
beautiful Alan can you see that that ice
cube it is so cool right here you could
do it oh my gosh flowers in there you
could do just about any sliced garnish
yeah look at that isn't that oh yeah
that just adds to the whole wow just
beautiful
okay I need some booze in this yeah you
need a half an ounce of the luxado
Maraschino this one okay and then one
and a half of the Wheatley vodka which
uh won best of show at the tag Awards
last year for bringing the good stuff it
is good stuff all right now Sherry all
right add all of that fruit right into
the punch all of it and generally the
idea with garnish is to tie in the
ingredients in the actual punch so we
have sliced grapes with the grape juice
we have lemons we have oranges and then
open that bottle of champagne well I
thought you'd never asked yes okay all
right here we go
and then you can just pour that right in
so if you're making one okay that's
exactly what you would do and if you're
making a batch like we have here oh how
beautiful is that really trust me to do
this yeah oh oh yeah are you ready
everybody watch out
okay hold on okay
party should we get a professional in
here
there it is okay go ahead all right
beautiful rabbit it's wet oh there we go
there it is all right everything's
better with bubbles sure if you want to
start scooping this up a little bit you
betcha okay oh that's wonderful okay so
this is perfect Tony for the gals now
really quick while we're scooping this
up we've got your book here I mean you
are responsible for some of the biggest
bar openings in the country you are the
modern mixologist and you've got a book
with some cocktail recipes that are
pretty outstanding well thank you very
much Heather actually this is a drink I
call a pink flamingo it is in my book
The Modern mixologist and I made it for
my sister-in-law Janet and all her gal
Pals so oh look at this well cheers
Valentine's Day and all that gowns
more uh
oh that is good oh that's great oh we're
gonna have a good day afternoon
delicious yes
thank you delicious